minor attracted persons okay so this is
a uh let's just get into it no no I'm
gonna intro this is a sex therapist
she's gonna give it yourself very
Erie Pennsylvania who is saying that
people who are attracted to children who
now they've [ __ ] rebranded pedophiles
as minor attracted persons I can't
believe that's real there's a lot of
stuff on the internet about Minor
attractive persons and how we're
supposed to be good to them go ahead
let's go let's rape children and make it
okay Miss Miranda I use she her pronouns
and I'm a licensed professional
counselor and sex therapist in Erie
Pennsylvania and today I want to talk
about Minor licensed person therapist
and I want to talk about Minor attracted
persons because they are probably the
most vilified population of folks in our
culture most folks are making incorrect
assumptions about them without actually
knowing much about them and those
assumptions create harm for an already
marginalized population she just called
pedophiles a marginalized population
yeah no no yeah yeah no way you may have
enough honest that I'm using the term
minor attractive persons sometimes
abbreviated to Maps instead of the more
commonly used term pedophile and I'm
doing this because the term pedophile
has moved from being a diagnostic label
to being a judgmental hurtful insult
that we hurl at people okay so here's
where she gets I'm guessing she gets
that thinking from so you know how the
word [ __ ] it's a bet I know I use it
sometimes it comes out it's a bad word
we're not supposed to say the r word
it's an insult it's an insult it was
originally introduced into our language
as a medical term people were mentally
[ __ ] means they they were basically
just you know mentally slow in
development so then but it became a
commonplace the general population
picked it up and like hey you [ __ ]
right so now she is taking that and
making pedophile a parallel oh so
pedophilia being a condition yeah but
like mental retardation but now
pedophilia is an insult no no it's not
yeah because pedophilia is raping
children well the thing is it's not even
used in the same connotation that [ __ ]
is used like you just call people who
are being stupid retards but if someone
is like if you're like 40 talking to a
20 year old no one's calling you a
pedophile if anything they're calling
you a creep even though I don't think
that's weird but it's not like that word
is being used in the same way that
[ __ ] is being used but if you're Joe
Biden and your daughter says and your
daughter
hours later
late at night you're pedophile so yeah
so now we're gonna normalize pedophilia
and minor and call them minor attractive
I also prefer person first language that
recognizes that any label we might apply
to a person is only part of who they are
and doesn't represent everything that
they are that's true we are all I'll
tell you all this what do I tell you
about Hitler
foreign
dogs Hitler love dogs so we should go we
should go put a picture of Hitler up at
the Peta Foundation give me a [ __ ]
break lady do you understand that's this
exact same logic as what she is saying
yeah it's just the other way around I
see what you're saying first we have
many different facets or parts of
ourselves and this includes folks who
are attracted to minors so to start with
let's talk about what a minor attracted
person is or who they are this term
simply means that we're interested in
learning an enduring sexual or romantic
attraction to minors they've not chosen
this attraction just as the rest of us
have not chosen whatever our attraction
is you don't get to choose to be
heterosexual or to be gay or whatever
you are and you don't get to choose to
be a minor attractive person some minor
attracted person I'll buy that or I'll
buy that they didn't choose to be a
minor attracted person maybe maybe no no
no no no no maybe they were raped as a
child listen maybe they're just [ __ ]
lunatics who need to be locked away but
let's not pretend that they deserve to
be a protected class that's the
difference I do buy some of what she's
saying what she's saying is true maybe
they are just naturally this way that's
fine that's the same logic you just get
to go in a [ __ ] cage because of that
that's the same logic as I'm chemically
I mean I don't know why no it's not
there's Insanity that this is straight
up insanity if I I just like to take the
word insane too too freely I like to
take personal accountability I don't
like to think that oh I'm just attracted
to this it's just it's just how it is
like I like to like think I have I have
control over my own mind to control what
I do because you're not a child rapist
deeper than that it goes deeper than
just than just who you're attracted to
it's a whole lifestyle of being able to
control your mind and what you think not
just they're just born this way
chemicals in your brain just you're just
born liking little kids you're just born
liking old ass people it's not like how
it is you see what I'm saying I do I
think we're misunderstanding each other
so what I'm saying is some people may be
sexually abused as a child so they're
it's proven that they're more likely to
be pedos so she's right in the sense
that you know this is who they are my
thing is she wants us to the The Next
Step that she wants is is us to just go
oh but they're still lovely and they can
be okay no my next step is take them and
throw them into a [ __ ] cage alone I
wonder what she thinks with a lion maybe
and leave it there the way you can see
some people who are God forbid have had
a leg cut off or they're physically
crippled in some way yeah there is that
exists in the brain too so somebody
that's a pedophile a minor attractive
person which I actually map I think
could be a great acronym for murder all
pedophiles let's get that going
okay you know what I'm saying though you
gotta look at it it's the big age range
of minors while some are not and some
minor attracted persons are exclusively
there's people out there trying to make
pedophiles sound like they're normal and
it's okay and it ain't okay pedophiles
pedophiles in cages that's the
conclusion there I don't give a [ __ ] you
can't tell me that a pedophile is a
normal person if you want to get your
bread up online you can watch this video
that I'm about to pop up and make sure
you join the Discord in my description
[Music]
[Music]